so can you hear it the roar of moral
outrage that still reverberating through
the chattering classes after last week's
Presidents Cup dinner and then only
event they screamed in horror yeah so
what young women employ to be attractive
and flirtatious yeah so what
lots of working-class women trade on
their looks to earn a living they're not
victims or sex slaves they don't need
saving by middle-class women from the
Financial Times or anywhere else listen
to me when I say men should never be
allowed to abuse or to rape women but
the response to this event was farcical
e disproportionate and because of it
hostess agencies are now closing
girls will no longer feature at sports
events putting Swain's
of working class women out of work so
well done you feminists you took away a
woman's choice and her right to work the
real tragedy here is there are battles
to be fought against equality and sex
scandals child grooming gangs women
being forced into marriage girls having
their genitals cut in the name of
culture while the feminist screaming as
loudly about those in justices as they
are about women who choose to use their
looks to earn a few quid well normally
of course I like to take a heavy subbing
pencil to your intros Carol but I have
to say I think I agree with every single
word I really really do we're speaking
almost within hours of formula 1 as you
rightly said but here's what I don't
understand here's what and I'm gonna
bring in a clip from someone who
allegedly was at the president of all
and was was got hacked by Sky News quite
rightly to talk about his associations
with it but if we can't have these young
women at the darts matches and we can't
have these young women well how come the
girls can dance the way they do on
Strictly Come Dancing because surely
that says well how come we even have
lingerie catalogs these women from my
understanding they choose to do it
they're not forced to do it at
knifepoint presumably Amanda Holden when
she comes out for Britain's Got Talent
or x-factor whichever it is and she was
exactly but again I think she's probably
in control let's go back to the to the
President's Club
this is Sky News getting to the doorstop
of Jimmy Tarbuck I never saw I never
heard
the bad language or innovation to them
and insinuations to them and there and I
left after I'd done market tell them to
go to London Airport and see had parties
going on if they want to see bug
behavior it has to be both ways it can't
be all men Jimmy Tarbuck change down the
years finally his central point is
correct I have no problem with I think
they're called the Chippendales I have
no problems with the girls who are
getting parrot going on a hen party and
the girl is gonna get married after
doing whatever she does as the male
dancers you have absolute that--what's
if that's what gets you through the
night we're like we are in a
ridiculously puritanical most Victorian
age and it is interesting most of the
women who we'll talk to who are
hostesses at that event all of them said
they had a great time none of them said
they'd been Harris there's been there's
been no complaints made to the hostess
agency arrestor by the hostess claims
there's no proof of that and there's
been no criminal charges brought against
anyone but we've got to stop
infantilizing these women and we because
you know that they don't know what to
expect when you're when you assign it
with the hostess agency in this
particular gig they were told to wear
sexy see-through dresses sexy knickers
and high heels now you know you're not
going to a meeting of the WI when you
get to a gig like that and let's not
forget a lot of these women as I said in
the intro that working-class women who
are using their looks and the fact they
have graveyards to do in a living what
scares me about this and all this man
those women what are they gonna do now
they may well end up going to sleazier
gigs they might well end up going to two
organizations that aren't monitored in
the way these hostess clubs are where
they are kept relatively safe and what
really hack Smee offers all these
feminists as we chose have been on
Twitter they have put women out of work
and they have lost children's homes
gonna say hundreds of thousands of
pounds I want to look at this from the
human angle here and that is that on
this point I agree with Nick agreeing
with Carole that this has got a bit out
of hand now whatever was alleged at this
press
this club dinner clearly needs to be
looked into and if there have been
abuses and excesses then they are
serious and they need to be taken with
the utmost seriousness but when we look
at the human cost it becomes difficult
to think that this has gone - not to
think that this has gone too far so
let's take an example so not only the
women the these women have lost their
jobs but I wanted to focus specifically
on the charities because the charity's
felt so shamed in taking the money that
was raised that they refuse to take tens
of thousands in some cases hundreds of
thousands of pounds for children's
hospitals now there are children in
intensive care care units who are on the
verge of life or death who desperately
need the attention and care but because
of somebody's whether we like it or not
this is where they are now they may be
correct political stances but they are
at the end of the day political stances
because of someone's ideological
position on the rights of men and women
a hospital is turning down money that
could save the lives of two the views of
the feminist twitter mob than save
children's lives and if I was a parent
who had a kid at one of those hospitals
because their two kids Hospital sort of
given money back I would be storming the
street I'm glad I do because I'm almost
too depressed to say anything else
listening to you guys this is from Great
Ormond Street Hospital you'll get over
it the expert medical treatment that
children receive at the hospital will
not be affected by the return of deals
donations great orders why they ask
people money
Great Ormond Street Hospital charity has
not taken the decision to repay this
money lightly and so basically or to
grant so so according to you guys if if
men aren't allowed to keep groping women
you have taken what you wanted about
sick children that was really our lives
no one said that
if I say that no it wouldn't make me did
you hear me saying that what did you
just say what just exploded did I say
that you were talking about sick
children nobody died say that if men
can't continue to grope women children
would die did I say that we're talking
about I'm really actually quite out
looking about the club yeah I'm
wondering what you've been talking about
the same story
yeah story I'm thinking of is a report
where a reporter went undercover and
discovered men groping women making
inappropriate sexual comments at a men's
only when she was asked to explain what
she meant by groping do you know what
she said with the example she gave a man
putting his hand in the small of a
woman's back she regards that as groping
is it okay for a man to do that to women
woman herself that is allegedly being
groped around a complaint then it's out
of order
and that guy who's doing the perv in or
whatever needs to be shoved out of that
Club and double-quick time in my opinion
okay I think if he's not doing anything
wrong other than just having a look
about what's right especially if the
girl knows that that's the sort of thing
she's got herself into just support a
little because I know none of us none of
us can down this but that offer is Right
the allegations a little bit more than
touching those suggestions of as I
mentioned exposing primates got one
teenage girl reportedly being so upset
she went to her boss or line manager who
said just I'll just slap his hand and
tell him as a naughty boy so that is the
sort of thing so after is right to say
that it was a far graver situation but
where I think none of us are condoning
that none of us can donor and you can
help me with this because you are an
expert in this field you almost written
books about this isn't the idea of
feminists to empower women so if a woman
does want to be a pitlane a grid girl or
woman does want to come out to start a
darts match and she does it she's not
exploited she knows what should she
should be able to do Fermin ism is about
men and women being equal right so my
issue just apart from the specific
allegations around actually that's the
definition of feminism is the Equality
of men and women it's about and it's
also about women being able to make
choices it's the basic definition at its
core it's about a qualification take it
or visit the reason I say that is
because this is about a context in which
there is not an equal power balance
society between men and women so the
idea that it's okay that that
working-class women need to be able to
be objectified by men in order to have
jobs no that's not not everyone gets the
chance to go to Oxford or be educated
it's really interesting that you keep
saying this is only about working-class
women when I I've been wearing these
jeans I've done since I was 14 to earn
my you know money for myself and one of
the jobs I did was waitressing right and
I never done hostessing like this but
the amount that these wouldn't be fair I
think it's 120 pounds a night is about
250 about double or three times what I
made with the host of the waitressing
jobs I can see why young women who are
students or because they need a source
of income
so not just working-class women would do
this kind of most now you are often as a
young woman in the workplace where you
need money in a vulnerable position
where you have all the powerful rich men
in all kinds of ways trying to take
advantage and actually just to put some
context here a survey 2016 by the TEC
found that half of women in the UK from
all class backgrounds have experienced
sexual harassment work and the workplace
talk was specifically talking about it's
really important four out of five did
not report it for fear of having
consequences for employment so when you
say that deals why are these girls the
president's club completely happy
because the agency said so they asked my
point without your point to the age of
society on an agency if your income does
it ever occur to you that some girls
like the glamour of these events they're
like the fact that it's easy money
the girls or the papers today this
party's other girls work for me am i
posting events and that sort of thing
they've never ever want to complain to
me and I can tell you now if there was
anything untoward happened to all those
girls they go straight away and if it
was a police complaint to be had then
that would happen as well so we're not
condoning any of that ridiculous
behavior and we are so